I love you then,
it is time for Drew's News.
Your good news alley-oop.
We pass you the ball for the good news slam dunk.
And with me at the desk,
is the best co-pilot in the biz, Rusty Ross Matthews.
I got it, I got it, catch.
(audience cheers)
Yeah, oh, oh.
Nothing but net.
All right, well, first up, this was interesting.
The movie "Dune" has 10 Oscar nominations
and is getting a sequel.
Oh wow.
(audience cheers)
And Timothée Chalamet and Zendaya will be back
for part two
but the Hollywood Reporter says
they might be joined by none other than,
oh, I'm not kidding.
One of my favorite actresses in the world
and rocked it as Scar Joe's sister in "Black Widow",
Florence Pugh.
Love her.
(audience cheers)
She's in talks to play Princess Irulan
and the deal is not final,
but this is where it gets interesting,
Florence is one of the very finalists
for the Madonna movie to play Madonna
but they film at the same time.
Oh, plot twist.
You know, agents are so hot to trot right now.
They're like, buy, sell, buy, sell, you can have her.
You can't have her.
You want her, you gotta pony up.
I mean, this is so fun.
Hollywood bananas.
Yeah, Dune, so they're making a second Dune?
They just weren't Dune'd yet?
The first one, I didn't, did you watch Dune?
I haven't seen Dune yet.
I started, it was really tan.
Like it was just tope after tope after tope.
Do you guys know?
It was like the whole color scheme was just, I was bored.
I feel like it came out at a time
where I had a little bit of depression
and I was like, I can't do it.
Yeah.
I can't go to a dry, miserable planet.
I just, I can't do it.
Like I couldn't watch The Handmaid's Tale
in the middle of a divorce, but then a few years later
when I got my spine back, I was like, bring it on.
Bring it on.
Well, I'm gonna watch Dune, 10 Oscar nominations.,
Apparently it's great.
Everybody loves it.
Yeah, right.
We're missing out.
I'm gonna watch this one before Dune 2 comes out, okay.
That's a promise.
All right, your story.
All right, next up a news
about another one of our favorite actors, Chris Pine.
Yeah.
(audience cheers)
Whether you know him from "Star Trek"
or "Princess Diaries 2",
Allure reports you've never quite seen him like this.
Take a look.
He's out in LA recently, sporting a big old bushy beard.
He went from clean-cut to grizzly man
and Pine can pull it off.
He did look like this in "Hell or High Water",
Remember that movie?
It was so good.
I didn't see that one either.
Oh, it was good.
It was good.
And don't let the beard distract
from the leggings and the clogs.
Can you look at that again?
Oh.
Yeah, I'm really into this look on Chris Pine.
I feel like we need to zoom in on his face.
Bingo.
A little closer then, oh.
(audience cheers)
There we go.
He looks like a sexy Wookiee.
Like a sexy Wookiee?
Yes, yes.
What's a Wookiee?
I don't know a Wookiee.
Chewbacca is a Wookiee.
Oh, Chewbacca's a Wookiee?
Yeah or should I say?
(Wookiee sounds)
(upbeat music)